the US will soon unveil what are called
the toughest and most aggressive
economic sanctions ever on North Korea
Vice President Mike Pence made that
announcement this morning in Tokyo
without providing details he will lead
the American delegation for the Winter
Olympics in South Korea Ken said the US
will continue its quote maximum pressure
campaign until North Korea takes
concrete steps toward complete
verifiable and irreversible
denuclearization
we also learned this morning that Kim
jong-un's sister will join North Korea's
delegation to the Pyeongchang Olympics
CBS News senior global affairs
contributor Ian Bremmer is the president
of the Eurasia group good morning so
much to talk about let's start with
first vice president pence not ruling
out that he would have some high-level
talks with a North Korean official while
he's there what could that mean well
first of all the tougher sanctions he's
promising it's not like the United
States is doing any business with North
Korea so that means hitting the Chinese
hitting their banks hitting their
corporations working with the North
Koreans we've already been talking about
a much tougher trade stance towards the
Chinese that's a big deal but pence has
not ruled out talking to the North
Koreans both going to be there around
the Olympics now that he's played tough
the ability of the United States to also
engage diplomatically in the way the
South Koreans already are there's
clearly an opening there the North
Koreans are showing all of this
diplomacy sports diplomacy sending
high-level officials their symbolic head
of state as well as now their sister her
first trip to South Korea all of this is
on the back of pressure from the Trump
administration so there is an
opportunity that's been set up by Trump
she's not clear if they can take it well
does it mean that the Trump's stand the
end of strategic patience is working
well let's put it this way it makes it
more likely there's a breakthrough and
it makes it more likely that we
incinerate a couple million Koreans and
I mean both of those are on the table
right now and the question is do you
like the uncertainty so if this means
more pressure on China these sanctions
that the vice president's talked about
but hasn't detailed does that mean China
is not doing its job in pressuring North
Korea because there been conflicting
signals from the administration on
whether China's being helpful or not the
Chinese are doing more than they have
under either the Obama or Bush
administration's they've supported
significantly
Kotori unanimous sanctions at the UN
Security Council they are cracking down
on smuggling across the border they've
limited joint ventures but with the
North Koreans that was leading to money
in North Korea but they're not prepared
to cut them off because they're
concerned of what would happen if the
Korean North Korean regime implodes now
that is going to prevent Trump / saying
that they're doing enough he is pointing
the finger there and Trump is also
pointing the finger at the Chinese
because we're expanding our trade
deficit with them we're not getting
access to their to their economy so a
lot of things that are playing out at
the same time North Korea is only one of
those pieces and go ahead well so how
much of this is theater so we also hear
about those so-called bloody nose strike
this idea of a possible limited strike
against North Korea how much of this is
actually being thought of these big
sanctions this bloody nose and how much
of it is a part of kind of threatening
in order to pull back or as a part of
the negotiating power I think the fact
that on the day of the State of the
Union Victor cha who was meant to be the
ambassador to South Korea pulled out
because he had privately been pushing
the White House I'm told HR McMaster
national security adviser saying this
isn't gonna work
and McMasters like that's it you're done
that's not a good step because clearly
Trump himself wants a viable military
option and when you talk to the
intelligence analysts in the US
government that know the most about
North Korea we've got the signals
intelligence we've got the satellite
imagery we have no human intelligence at
all there's no one out there that
believes that they have a bead on how
one of the most brutal leaders in the
world would respond to a bloody node's
preemptive strike against his country I
want to go back to the sister for a
second I heard you say that it's her
first trip but what's the significance
because I think most people don't even
know he had a sister
and number two he seems like such a lone
wolf so what is her role
she's known she's politically engaged
she's president occupying the role I
believe that her aunt used to but no one
knows exactly what that means in terms
of decision-making I think what we can
say with a fair amount of certainty is
that the fact that she's going implies
that there is a message a direct message
from Kim jong-un going to the South
Korean government and
and it really is an effort to say never
mind these Americans we can work
together which the South Korean
president is interested in look this
whole idea of good-cop bad-cop would be
useful if the South Koreans and the
Americans were working together on this
but they're not right so the South
Koreans pushed back on joint exercises
with the Americans to make sure the
limbic swill fine
Secretary of Defense mattis wasn't aware
of that and they're marching together in
the opening ceremonies with in South
Korea together
yeah that's says something thank you
very much in Bursa good to have you at
the table